c'est un vieux serpent de mer dont on
parle depuis les années 90 la ligne
nouvelle paris-normandie le 20 novembre
dernier un nouveau comité de pilotage
s'est réuni avec état sncf et parties
concernées pour lancer la phase 2 du
projet pour rappel la lnpn est un grand
projet ferroviaire qui doit se dérouler
en trois étapes et qui a pour objectif
de rallier plus rapidement la normandie
et paris
la première étape s'est achevée fin 2020
et la deuxième s'est ouverte avec ce
comité de pilotage où est ta région
ile-de-france et régions normandie ont
validé le financement et le lancement
d'une nouvelle phase d'étude et de
concertation
cette deuxième étape doit aussi définir
les tracés entre paris et mantes en
ile-de-france est rond et barentin en
normandie
et c'est le tracé francilien qui a posé
problème au département des yvelines
en effet l'état a retenu le tracé sud
plutôt que deux autres choix cela
impliquerait donc que la lnpn
traverserait en souterrain la forêt de
saint-germain-en-laye de ce côté pas ou
peu de problèmes
en revanche la sortie du tunnel à
hauteur de hors jeu valve pose question
et inquiète les élus yvelinois la lnpn
doit ensuite rejoindre morainvilliers
puis mantes-la-jolie et enfin la
normandie mais sur ce tracé figurent des
champs captant des terres agricoles ou
encore des habitations depuis novembre
dernier c'est donc l'incompréhension qui
règne comme en atteste le vice président
délégué aux mobilités pour le
département des yvelines
ça c'est acceptable ni pour le
département des yvelines ni pour les
agriculteurs dans l'absolu nous sommes
pas obstiné nous ne sommes pas contre
quelque chose on demande simplement que
ce soit compatible
il faut que cette ligne qui a son
intérêt pour les normands ne soit pas
qu'une addition d'inconvénients pour un
des départements traversés par l'invs
c'est ça la difficulté est chez légitime
l'autre interrogation est donc
inquiétude c'est le financement
le coût global avoisinerait les 6
milliards d'euros la ligne nouvelle
paris normandie est espéré pour 2030
mais le projet date des années 90 alors
rien n'est moins sûr de voir émerger
cette nouvelle ligne ferroviaire dit
dix ans